[Music]
so a lot of people have been very bored
throughout this entire pandemic and have
a lot of different hobbies right nikki
lots of hobbies more than a how about
you never have too many hobbies more
than a hot board in the house
well do you think you can take up the
hobby
of teaching your cats how to communicate
with you
oh yeah yeah oh is this about that thing
where they figured out that thing
what thing about how the cats what were
they really saying
oh the meow i use it all the time by the
way do you use it
i did for a while but it's the same
thing every day it says the same [ __ ]
overnight i'm like my cats are born they
only say the same thing they say i love
you mommy
all the time i'm like i get it you love
me well maybe they don't have an
extensive
vocabulary also i can never catch my
cats but no this one is
i always say i'm in pain to me for some
reason i'm not
i'm not kidding it always says i'm in
pain i'm like the [ __ ]
sucks i'm like i'm starting music i'm
not using this app it's actually like
feel i feel bad
my mind pops up i'm in pain a lot too
and i'm like no that's not it
it's like it lets you say like yes or no
no you're declined
i don't want to know i know my cat
better than you just to catch you up
there's this app
what the [ __ ] this is an app that can uh
capture
what translates yeah whatever noise your
cat makes it tells you what
it's actually saying um you just keep
recording it fifteen or like twenty
oh it's an ad oh crazy called me i'll
talk nothing not talk
but yeah so no no so this has nothing to
do with that okay this one
is about so there's this
linguistics no sorry she's a speech
language pathologist that's what she is
she started training her dog to
communicate with her with
these little buttons oh yeah seen that
on tick tock yes i follow them on tick
tock
yeah so the one that started this her
name is christina hunger
and she's based in san diego she's a
hungry she she began training her
dog named stella as a puppy back in 2018
and like i said she was using these
little buttons that had like each button
it has a different word like go outside
or i want to go on a walk
yeah i'll show you a video right now and
so she just started adding more and more
buttons
and this turned into her house it's wild
it's amazing multiple people doing it
and now you're probably talking about
bunny she yes she's
popular bunny is another dog that's
popular on tik tok and they actually
she uses a different different style
like with these hex
tiles that it's from a program and i'll
get more into it in a second but i'm
gonna show you guys this video
why are dogs so nice oh yeah that was
different
here we go this is stella so this is the
first dog that stella's a doberman no
i like it it's like a lab but stella's
not involved with the hex tiles
program that's a separate program so
here we go
come come
he wants water thirsty maybe
the kayak is for the water you're right
that's the one what does it say that's
the one i saw too
sound bird you hear a bird so she's like
she's showing
that she can hear the birds on the water
right now
what i love it so much i love it
oh i do you're crows how cute
damn they got lightning [ __ ] ears
okay that looks like a kid in a [ __ ]
dog costume
we love you why went
why when why did you go yeah
i like the way the dog looks dad went
dad went to get food
dad what if he just accidentally hit
some buttons
so i'll go into that
dead bye that's right oh he's
communicating
dude look at the wheels looking at the
cameras this [ __ ] tripping me out
he's like looking at her like [ __ ] i
already told you what i'm saying what
don't you understand
i said where'd dad go is he like humans
are so [ __ ]
dumb bro he's like will this [ __ ] push
some buttons please
[Laughter]
yeah so these buttons they're calling
them aac
devices so augmentative and alternative
communication device
and so this is this system is used by
humans that have language problems
and so it's just like conveying concepts
with combinations
of up to five words at a time to
communicate with people
and so christina she was the one that
started doing this
with her puppy which sparked an idea in
this like these other people like these
other scientists that
they ended up creating this project
called they can talk
and it's a series of psycho-linguistic
studies
seeking to document non-humans
expressing themselves in language-like
ways
but in the studies in the past they
would only focus on the capacity of
a single animal like coco the gorilla
kanzi the chimpanzee or rico the dog
but this one this they can talk project
is
a large open source oh wow citizen study
science study yeah and so people could
go on their website and sign up to
participate in this
and so it's mainly a lot of like dog
trainers uh language specialists
um and they're and crazy dog people as
well
bother those two do you think the dogs
are asking questions or making
statements
because the way that they the humans are
responding is like
it's like it's like they're answering a
question but then
in the dog's mind it might just be like
they're blurting out things like
like a kid does right or like whatever
that's exactly what they're comparing it
to so they're comparing
these animals like as like how toddlers
communicate
so just the way toddlers communicate
they'll sometimes point out an
observation
or they'll they'll make requests like
i'm hungry or whatever it is
um so right now they're saying that more
than a thousand dogs
50 cats and a few horses are involved
whoa
you got to get some powerful buttons
that's wild that they have thought like
that
i don't want birds outside no i already
have a toddler now imagine a toddler and
two other [ __ ] screaming like [ __ ]
dogs
outside and i'm gonna be like it's like
i'm hungry the dog's like hungry
younger exactly like shut the [ __ ] up
everybody
you can hide the machine and bart's like
i'm hungry
me too and then your horse is like i'm
hungry everyone's hungry
the cat is hungry no the cat's like i'm
in pain
i'm in pain that's what mine says god
pain but yeah so it's really interesting
and yeah like what you're saying it's
just it's
giving humans an insight into how
animals
are more than what we already see them
as like they have their own
thoughts i mean like it blows my mind
that people
think that they don't yes i'm like what
the [ __ ] kind of idiot planet do you
live on that you don't think that
you just never had a connection to
animals i just made the statement gio
and then you're gonna go ahead and say
what kind of [ __ ] dumbass says
i just said it it's really good it's
really good when steve and i first
started dating
when steve and i first started dating
one of those kind of people like
and i was like i am people i am he was
like yeah people that think that they
know what their cat wants and like they
know like
oh he's he's tired he wants blah blah
blah and now he is that
yeah does this change of
now thinking that they're just impulsive
creatures but there's actual
thought and motive behind what their
actions are
because my whole thing is this we'll
finally be able to figure out
if there are ghosts or not because we
know that dogs can see ghosts
so they'll be like girls behind you yeah
run away earthquake bad guy do you know
that they
they do balance their motive because
when they [ __ ] up
their ears are down and then they don't
can't even look at you know my favorite
kind of video is
looking at dogs in trouble that's my
favorite because it's so bad
cats give a [ __ ] at my house you're
right zoe gets really scared when
he knows that i found out that he's shat
on the [ __ ] so they know when they're
not they did something they weren't
supposed to do
they had they feel regret and then also
when you like you have an animal and you
pay attention
like they make their own decisions all
the time i love it you see like a dog
go pick up a stick and he runs over
there he's playing with the stick and
goes nah i don't care about him
he drops it on the ground and he just
like you see them make constant
decisions
dude i love when i had a dog i would
throw it at
her lick the ball she brings it all the
way up to me and then just drops it in
front of me instead of handing it to me
like she's almost like pick it up pick
it up [ __ ] pick it up every time you
want to deal with the pause
yeah i wanted to go from pod to from
mouth to hand from potiphar i heard you
so easy and they all have different
personalities too that's how come crazy
cat people or crazy dog people get that
way because
we love all their different
personalities like my one cat is like
the schedule keeper
and he has to be on the same schedule
every time and routinely like keep all
the other cats in line
and make sure that they're all in the
same schedule and so he'll wake me up
to go feed the other cats and then he'll
supervise and just make sure everybody
eats
and if they don't eat he'll make sure
they eat how does he do that he's the
chaperone he likes he blocks he blocks
the doorway
oh [ __ ] yeah he makes sure they eat and
then after everyone's done
then he goes over there and eats and
then our other cat pees in our head so
it's really and he has no guilt about it
he has a personality
he's a different personality i feel like
that's how aliens
observe us you're like did you watch
those guys on jk news okay so one guy
you know he's always like riding around
aliens watch our show yeah they're
tuning in
damn they're bored i mean joel rogan's
been
posting about how aliens have been
confirmed so
we're gonna talk about that later okay
we're talking about that but i think
that they watch us like the way we watch
dogs you look like you are an
alien person right now oh that's how he
knows like you've been on the satellites
right now do you think the aliens
skip the ads or are they like i like
these guys i'll sit through this
i hope so i hope it's the latter i hope
so and i hope they use our coupon codes
too
yeah i hope so yeah i hope they help
keep us alive in their patreons too yeah
yeah thank you
you hope that their heimlich maneuvered
here at least i know right that'd be so
cool
shout outs to the aliens thank you grace
thank
we don't discriminate just to be careful
everyone's cool yeah yep
all right well anyways back to this
project here so a lot of people
criticizing this project they're saying
that they could a lot of the humans
involved
it could like un unlock something no no
they could be they could probably have
confirmation bias
and so like we don't know if these
animals are
truly communicating oh [ __ ] off who
cares it's a good old time it's just fun
we're just trying to believe in
something so the researchers
said that they will eventually be making
house calls to ensure that the data
sent in is systematic and objective
they said the ultimate test is
documenting how reliable
how how reliably science pets do it is
the way that they do it consistent do
they use the same order when they
produce multi-button combinations wow
way to make something fun [ __ ] boring
guys yeah
scientists always do that it's a
scientific study they have to
[ __ ] science why can't we just
believe
dude my brother-in-law's a scientist
he's the most boring person i know by
the way i know
any scientist that doesn't believe in
santa [ __ ] stupid true
yeah just pretend that santa's there
play [ __ ]
[Music]
you